[Música]
eu vim e eu quero convidar vocês pra
ouvir uma história é uma história que
vai ser super legal porque o
participante principal dessa história o
personagem número 1
são vocês
olha aqui todos vocês e essa história
que vai falar sobre inovação começa
assim vocês vão morrer antes dos 40 anos
mas que tiro foi esse acordo já de cara
assim no segundo slides pois é o motivo
é que vocês vivem nessa história em 1803
são da realeza britânica como os
soltados e nessa era em 1800 as pessoas
não vivem mais do que 40 anos a
expectativa de vida em 1840 anos 95% das
pessoas nessa era de viviam na extrema
pobreza
noventa por cento das pessoas eram
analfabetas vocês faziam parte dessa
última estatística e vocês vão gostar
nem um pouco na questão da longevidade
você queria ter uma vida próspera demais
e você pára e pensa e olha porchat até
os grandes artistas da época que vivem
dentro dos castelos cercados por duque 6
não tiveram tal sorte de ter uma
actividade melhor e você viu os
cientistas
puxa vida por colados na tecnologia em
acesso a todo tipo de tratamento e
também não tem a sorte de ter uma
longevidade melhor que até então um dia
você toma decisão só no seu cavalo e vai
em busca da maga do seu filé a bruxa e
que nesse caso aqui amarga eu vou
homenagear a minha sogra dela se chama
de erenice então você vai conversar com
mangabeira disse
ela fala pra você escolhe
triste o que realmente acontece
mas eu já vi todas as formas e magias e
eu tenho duas opções pra vocês ao seu
número um você tomar essa posição
vermelha e você vai se ver em uma outra
região
outro mundo outra é que nessa outra era
você vai poder ser o protagonista
escolher sua história
ou senão você continua na nossa era é e
eu te enche de riqueza mas você vai
viver a mesma é que nós temos aqui 800 e
você fecha o olho você pensa que são
vocês o protagonista quero que vocês
tomar a decisão vocês pensam o que vocês
querem em 321 a decisão da maioria foi
vocês nascerem novamente 1985 no
interior de minas gerais
outra outro pai de outro ponto um
desenho feliz e que com dois anos de
idade o seu pai descobrem que você não
tá enxergando muito bem então eu te levo
uma moça chamada oftalmologista
ela coloca na sua frente lentes que
tornam o em passado indefinido e naquele
momento você tem um primeiro contato com
a tecnologia que enquanto a sua vida
você pode passar a ter acesso à
alfabetização
essa tecnologia tão simples que todos
nós estamos acostumados a viver com ela
o óculos que transforma em si pode ser
board é o conceito disse 'porque é
quando você utiliza uma tecnologia
embarcada em seu corpo
o governo desempenharam a função que
você não funciona muito bem que você não
tem muito bem não precisa ser uma mão
mecânica
o próprio óculos já nos torna se borges
então três dias depois falar você
há três anos de idade os anos e óculos
se o povo me deu
você passa a enxergar todo mundo
aos oito anos você em sua casa um atalho
que é um videogame e coisa que o game
você se diverte com seu pai de montão
e esse que o game desenvolve em você
características que nunca imaginou
raciocínio espacial raciocínio
matemático rapidez nas respostas e você
torna um cérebro muito mais avançado do
que 1.800 você teria a possibilidade aos
você já maravilhado por toda a
tecnologia que existe você decide que
seu propósito é trabalhar com a
tecnologia
e nessa mesma era chega pra você a
internet que traz todos os dados do
mundo pra frente a sua bela voz e agora
terá senhor do mundo tem acesso a todas
as informações
com 22 anos de idade você receber um
upgrade
não sei se porque isso você anexa onde
vale se o seu corpo aquilo mexe no bolso
um pequeno de varzim que muda sua vida
quando você passa a ter um poder de
conversar com qualquer pessoa do mundo
em qualquer lugar do mundo
mandando fotos montando áudios fazendo o
que você quiser e se levar se agrega em
você também a capacidade de conhecer
todas as ruas do planeta todos os
interessados sem ter que decorar a nata
ou seja recebe liberdade de poder ir e
vir qualquer lugar do planeta
iam levar disse que vai recebendo os
ingredientes novas funcionalidades e
novos poderes e você se sente um
ciborgue completo com esse do varzim
toda tecnologia gente
é que é o seu corpo então você prepara
pense tudo aquilo que você viveu lembra
da marca berenice fala sensacional essa
mulher envolvida em um super homem
ela me transformou em um dos gols e até
que um dia algo terrível acontece a sua
vida algo que não esperava aquele seu
pai que jogava com você atari é
diagnosticado com mal de alzheimer
aos 50 anos e 1 50 empresas e favorece
aquilo te deixa extremamente a palavra
você mergulha novamente na tecnologia
para pesquisar e começa a descobrir que
já existem raças tecnologia de
inteligência artificial sendo aplicadas
para ajudar na saúde por exemplo câncer
pessoas que têm câncer
hoje os médicos podem ter acesso a
tratamentos superespecializadas baseado
em inteligência artificial porque a cura
seja mais rápido possível
na sua pesquisa sobre o mal de alzheimer
se descobre que não há cura mas que
chama livros sendo publicados lá
exterior e que pode te ajudar
então em três dias você compra
digitalmente recebe esse livro na sua
casa três dias
o livro vem de estados unidos você
engole o livro e mais três dias e
descobre que o mal de alzheimer é
causado por dois fatores a topper 11 a
sua genética do número 2 o seu estilo de
vida
então você raramente muda seu estilo de
vida você tem ação sobre ele possa comer
uma alimentação que faz sentido pra
aquela sua predisposição e olha você
pode fazer isso criar sua dieta que se
está a viver nessa era aquela outra era
impossível você selecionar próprias para
poder escolher e fazer a sua própria
dieta
três dias depois você descobre que
existe
a forma de você fazer o seu mapeamento
genético por apenas 140 dólares
então você cospe um pouco de saliva um
tubo de ensaio e manda para o
laboratório que prepara um relatório
para você completo com o seu mapa
genético com todas as informações de
onde vieram seus gênios e você espera
ansiosamente
até que um dia chega o resultado esse
resultado não vai por caixa
esse resultado tem digitalmente e quando
você abre você vai diretamente no campo
da sua predisposição ao mal de alzheimer
e você descobre que não hesitou
abrangente que causa o mal estar e isso
muda a sua vida novamente amada
erenice não te qual todo mundo inclusive
a você tem o futuro pela frente e você
começa a mergulhar ainda mais na
pesquisa de novas tecnologias em como as
tecnologias pode transformar a vida das
pessoas
e você vê que não só sua empresa mas
outras empresas já estão criando
tecnologias como por exemplo o um
dispositivo que amarrada ao seu braço e
conectado à internet faz com que os
séculos possam correr maratonas
esse dispositivo que é colocado no braço
do século cria muros virtuais na cidade
onde tem a maratona e o cego começa a
correr se ele começa a sair da posição o
braço vibra
é como se estivesse esbarrando no vidro
no mundo virtual e ele continua correndo
você vê que a inteligência artificial
que era algo de laboratório em pouco
tempo já está na sua vida
inúmeros bancos já estão utilizando essa
tecnologia para conversar com você
em linguagem natural e resolver o seu
problema de uma forma muito simples e
muito tiver não são bancos
carros que podem agora fazer até manuais
cognitivos para que o usuário possa
descobrir aquela informação de uma forma
muito rápida não é só também a
inteligência artificial que está botando
do mundo
você vê também pessoas utilizando a
realidade aumentada engenheiros que
podem perder o projeto que ainda não
está pronto e projetado em ambiente real
para poder saber se é que vai ficar
perfeito
enfim é o mundo magnífico que você está
vivendo
você teve a sorte de fazer a escolha
certa e você olha para o futuro eo
futuro não é mais aquela coisa distante
que vai mudá lá na frente o futuro já
está mudando agora cada um deles
as tecnologias chegam mais rapidamente
então você sabe que em poucos anos a
robótica vai para a casa de todos nós e
você vai ter bolsa utilizando a
inteligência artificial a um preço muito
mais barato do que o mapeamento genético
de 140 dólares
você vai ter também um avanço tremendo
na ciência médica utilizando
inteligência artificial utilizando
genética e tornando a potencialidade do
ser humano ainda maior e não só de saúde
e trabalho as pessoas dizem as pessoas
querem se divertir ea rede social muito
cedo vai deixar de ser algo feito numa
tela parcial feito presencialmente
usando realidade virtual você vai poder
dançar numa balada com aquele seu amigo
que botou panos boa até com certo dia
outra coisa acontece na sua vida você
recebe um convite um convite muito
especial convidando vocês pra mim
palestrar no pendentes
o objetivo da sua apresentação e falar
sobre tecnologias emergentes no mundo da
revolução industrial
você pára e olha esse mundo que
ainda vivendo pensa como foi a história
do ser humano nos últimos 200 anos e
tenta buscar o que está por trás da
tecnologia que realmente algo duradouro
que vai viver para todo sempre as
tecnologias na verdade elas são muito
perecíveis elas deixam se chegue
rapidamente então você conclui
claramente e passa o recado para sua
platéia que o desenvolvimento de
tecnologia é 100% focado na melhora da
vida das pessoas
todos nós que trabalhando trabalhando e
desenvolvendo tecnologia queremos fazer
a vida das pessoas melhor desenvolvidos
com ética sempre pensando com uma
tecnologia que se invisível como a
tecnologia pode encaixar no dia a dia
das pessoas de forma com que as pessoas
não têm que se mudar e moldar a
tecnologia
o inverso acontece e quando isso
acontece a tecnologia entra na vida das
pessoas em todos os lugares das formas
mais diversas possíveis e ao entrar na
vida de todas as pessoas
a tecnologia quebra barreiras à
realidade da rede de conhecimento
hoje pessoas cegas podem correr
maratonas pessoas muitas podem conversar
utilizando a sap então essas barreiras
deixam de existir e uma tecnologia que
você sente está no seu corpo e que não
tem barreiras entra na sua casa na sua
família e muda a forma de você viver em
qualquer lugar onde você estiver
então nesse último momento
no final da sua vida você diante da sua
palestra de tete
você fala e pensa que você quer dizer
a coisa só pra poder pessoal vocês todos
líder a quarta revolução industrial
vocês vivem em uma era em que todos
vocês são super-heróis todos vocês
herdar séculos de desenvolvimento e de
conhecimento feito por dezenas de
gerações
isso não é só uma sorte isso é um legado
moral que vocês recebem e um legado
moral nos força a pensar em que
propósito a gente quer ter na nossa vida
e como a gente vai aproveitar o máximo
pra gente passar esse legado para o
resto do mundo e fazer com que a vida de
todas as outras pessoas seja ainda
melhor do que a que a gente viu obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]